[Music]
from Disney the studio that will soon
make every one of the movies you see
comes a movie made for everyone from
ten-year-old girls to people high on
shrooms to actually that's pretty much
it this one is really neat a wrinkle in
time enjoy the simple story of a girl
with low self-esteem finding her missing
father and learning to believe in
herself while at the same time director
Ava Duvernay pours LSD directly into
both your eyeballs in a bonkers mix of
grounded straightforward storytelling
and Reese Witherspoon transforming into
a giant flying leap Pokemon I am
freaking out man meet Meg a girl who
gets bullied about as much as Meg from
Family Guy yeah shut up Meg shut up Meg
when her dad pulls an interstellar and
crosses the universe with the power of
love
that's the frequency she'll team up with
her brother young Sheldon three fairy
godmothers and a cute boy who just kind
of wanders in what are you doing here I
don't know together
they'll find her dad on the set of
Drake's hotline bling' video and defeat
the embodiment of fear and negativity
that feeds on children known as it no
the other embodiment of fear negativity
that feeds on children known as it
that's the one get ready for more Eila
stars dressed like J pop idols than an
anime themed Met Gala featuring the
larger-than-life Weiss age known as
Oprah as a more grounded 100 foot tall
version of herself Reese Witherspoon as
your favorite we're dads warriors who
serve the good and light of the universe
and Mindy Kaling is that copy of
Bartlett's familiar quotations you leave
near the toilet tomorrow they'll be more
of us Maranda American the foot feels
the foot when it feels the ground
Napoleon Tucker American enough epic
voice guy internet so thrill at the
latest Disney juggernaut which enchanted
critics and made over a billion dollars
at the bottom wait what it wasn't a
critical success I'm underwhelmed and it
was a box-office disappointment and this
isn't the first time they screwed up
wrinkle in time that's impossible I mean
that just doesn't happen to Disney is
this a dream
no seriously is this a dream am I
dreaming right now man cuz I had a
couple of edibles before seeing the
movie and I'm just kind of waiting for
the second one to kick it Oh
starring the following lines from the
movie they've worked better is
motivational Instagram posts red anna
matthew mcconaughey boys love is always
there even if you don't feel it well
without love is like a tree without
blossoms are fruit the wound is the
place where the light enters you what if
we are not just in the universe the
universe is within all of us in order to
be great it isn't enough just to be
right love looks not with the eyes but
with a mind I wanted to shake hands with
the universe but I should have been
holding yours the Lisa Frank drinks to
you I give the gift of your faults
my gift it's my command note to self
don't invite Reese Witherspoon and Oprah
to your Secret Santa they're gifts suck
Avengers dinos Takes Manhattan
coming soon 2019 wood are we some kind
of Shrek for forever after the final
chapter whoa she it's a double Yoshi
explosion I think I got a pea shut up
Meg